my name is Safi el hello and this poem
is called
to make use of water
dilute I forget the Arabic word for
economy
I forget the English word for arson
forget the Arabic word for incense and
English word for miskeen Arabic word for
sandwich English verse o Dalia and madam
and wallahi stupid girl Atlanta got your
tongue
blur back home we are plagued by
politeness so dense even the doctors
cannot call things what they are
my grandfather is left i swirled thick
with smoke what my new mouth can call
glaucoma while the arabic still
translates to the white water
swim I want to go home dissolve I want
to go home
drown
half don't even make it out or across
you get to be ungrateful you get to be
homesick from safe inside your blue
American passport do you even understand
what was lost to bring you here for an
interview with the poet watch this video
or check out the next poem in this
series